foreign
[Music]
welcome to the stage vice president and
general manager of data and analytics
Garrett casmeyer
[Applause]
hi I am Garrett katzmeyer I am the VPN
GM of data analytics at Google Cloud
data analytics and AI are already having
a profound impact on how organizations
operate it helps them to become more
customer-centric
to innovate faster and to run more
sustainably so to get us started let's
take a look at how some of these
companies are doing this with Google's
data and AI Cloud today
juicy an adventure tourism company use
bigquery to build an AI driven customer
self-service portal
for instantaneous business insights and
to make fast decisions
now they are driving 97 of their sales
with zero human interaction
done in Bradstreet they combine their
data Lake and their data warehouse into
Google Cloud Storage with bigquery
they gained new analytics capabilities
and they built new data products
and all while improving the analytics
performance five times
Priceline uses bigbury's AI capabilities
and their own proprietary algorithms to
offer personalized services and to
recommend products to their customers
Price Line applies generated AI to offer
sophisticated trip planning suggestions
to their customers as well
and Priceline employees will benefit
from easier access to internal
information and realize real
productivity gains by automating some of
their time intensive content encoding
generation tasks with generative AI
SG Bank traditionally used on-premise
infrastructure but as they grew larger
as stake room more complex they realized
that this would become unsustainable
they moved their data architecture in a
single platform on bigquery
they interconnected
176 Banks they improved their data
sharing and all while reducing the data
infrastructure costs by 50 percent
and a big shout out to all of the tens
of thousands of bigquery customers out
there who are running billions of
queries who are analyzing exabytes of
data every day across Cloud isn't this a
mind-blowing scale
[Applause]
so before we go into what's next let's
hear from one of those customers
directly and how they are taking action
on their data with Google's data and AI
Cloud please welcome from Wendy's the VP
of data management and analytics Wendy
Erickson
hey Randy thank you thank you so much
for coming please have a seat
so to get us started for the ones who
don't know tell us a bit about Wendy's
great so Wendy's is the second largest
quick service restaurant hamburger chain
in the United States we have about 7 000
locations in more than 30 countries
Wendy's is a company that has Innovation
built into our DNA that really started
in about 1970 when Dave Thomas
introduced the first modern
drive-through changing the qsr industry
as we know it
today we're focused on global growth and
digital acceleration and with that we're
becoming a true digital technology
enabled company
so
of course we want to hear about the data
and AI strategy advantis of course
our strategy at Wendy's is to build a
centralized trusted source of Truth and
when we get everything centralized we
can take those pieces of data and
combine them into really rich insights
into what our business is doing we
leverage bigquery for our data lake
house which makes our information
available in relevant time and easily
accessible for our business to use it
provides us a really rich foundation for
us to tackle a variety of AI and data
use cases
for example I can tell you within
minutes of an order being completed
exactly what that order was I could take
that and then combine that with purchase
history and promotions that we have
coming and use that for Predictive
Analytics and demand forecasting
this solution along with some other data
helped Drive our decisions around our
Prime locations to build restaurants
and I can't forget to mention our most
exciting use case which is using
generative AI in our drive-through in
natural language
so you're serving customers customers
are very important and you build your
customer data platform on bigquery can
you sell why you built your CDP on top
of bigquery absolutely we made the
decision to build our CDP on top of
bigquery for multiple reasons first
customer data should drive every retail
business and it's certainly the core of
our business
making that not have another data Silo
and making it easily accessible for
others in our business was extremely
important to that
not to mention we have over three and a
half million monthly active users in our
loyalty program so we needed the
scalability of a platform like bigquery
to handle that load
um our second reason for doing this was
we needed to control our customer data
rather than allowing a tool to control
it for us this allowed us to pull that
data out of the tool making it available
for any of the tools and easily able to
switch out any of the customer
technologies that we might need to
finally we know that over 70 percent of
customers today expect a personalized
experience
and we needed to deliver that and so we
pulled our CDP out of any other platform
and put it into bigquery so that we
could build on things like Customer
Loyalty we could build product Affinity
groups and build greater personalization
we could then start to understand what
third party data how weather impacts our
consumer buying behaviors
no that is really interesting because
you just add better data and I know
you're using traffic data and all of the
data is you know is outside data right
so can you tell us a bit more how you
use third-party data sets in your data
landscape absolutely it's a critical
component for our data landscape for
many reasons so we use things like
traffic data and competitive Landscapes
to determine where the prime locations
to build new restaurants are
we use weather data and events data to
help us with preparing our inventory to
ensure we have enough inventory and hey
you may have heard of those super fund
Reggie Bush commercials that we have
that's because we have the third party
data that tells us 30 percent of our
customer base our football fans
I love it and you know well you know we
have to talk about AI right so of course
can you tell us a bit about the AI use
cases that you're building with you know
your data for vandies absolutely I think
we've just begun to scratch the surface
of the AI use cases that we'll see and
I'm super excited for Wendy's to lead
that Journey as I already mentioned we
do use voice AI in our drive through
this is a platform that Wendy's calls
fresh Ai and if you haven't done so I
encourage you to go check out the
Showcase that we have going on we won't
stop there though there's plenty of use
cases that we're testing out probably
the one that I'm the most excited about
has to do with solving a problem in the
data space
so we all know about the real challenges
of data data silos data accessibility
you know confidence in the data Reliance
on the technology teams to build out
visualizations of the data Wendy's is
currently testing multiple approaches
using generative AI on top of our
trusted data sources
to help solve that problem but think
about that I mean the possibilities are
endless when we get that right so many
of the people here many of the customers
right you know that that we hear about
they're all thinking about generative AI
right so as you said Randy's off to a
great start you know you have
implemented and actually operationalized
your first use case with generative Ai
and you know I really wonder you know
what helps Wendy being a tech leader and
an innovator in that space
built into our DNA as a company but
additionally I think our people are what
make the difference we have fantastic
Partnerships such as the partnership
that we have with Google we have a
really strong Business and Technology
leadership team we have a
forward-looking board of directors who
is always challenging us
and our CIO is known for doing the
impossible so we can't forget to mention
that
but equally important we have a really
strong relationship with our franchisees
and they are constantly volunteering
their restaurants to be early adopters
of these new technology advances so you
know last but certainly not least
I have to ask the question why did you
use a choose Google cloud and what is
the value that you have realized from it
yeah of course
um so we chose Google Cloud for multiple
reasons we needed the you know compute
power so it not only does it have the
compute power but the offerings that we
needed to make our business successful
you're also a leader in Innovation so
that adds to the mix what I would say is
things like the power of vertex AI
alongside of bigquery let us perform
things like sentiment analysis on social
media Impressions that we're listening
for if we take that data we can then add
in some of our operational data like
speed of service and labor reporting and
we can really start to understand what
is driving that social media impression
were we slow that day what was what was
going on in our restaurants that day
from there we can then run some what-if
scenarios and change different business
inputs to figure out what is the right
course of action to solve those problems
Google is also an innovator in Ai and
because of this we know that we can
deliver an elevated experience for our
customers in the drive-throughs
think about this for a second this is a
Monumental task that we're performing
together
our menu complexity is enormous there's
something more than 200 billion ways
that you can order a Dave's double that
is amazing right I have no idea yes 200
billion and the complexities are being
solved with what we're doing together
add in the noise and the issues that you
have with a drive-through speaker it
it's huge it's a huge task that we're
doing we also know that over 75 percent
of Wendy's customers choose the
drive-through as their ordering
preference so we have to get this right
but we're confident with Google being
our partner to get there that is so
awesome thank you Mandy for sharing your
amazing data and AI Journey with us
today absolutely thank you thank you
the power of AI really allows us to
re-imagine what we do how we do it and
who we do it for in virtually all parts
of an Enterprise
just like the example from mandis we now
have the most powerful technical
infrastructure and the best AI models at
our hands and for many companies it
feels like just being this one step away
from turning AI into your Enterprise AI
and start solving real business problems
like we just heard
that step is to activate your data with
AI your data is your most valuable and
your most differentiated asset
it's the key to unlock the power off AI
for your business it is the information
on how your business runs it's the
information on what makes you unique for
your customers and it can hold the
secrets for making it better for some
like the customers that we have just
heard about it is a small step to
activate our data with AI but for others
that step is as wide as a canyon
rendering an AI driven future a distant
dream
the solution is to understand data and
AI in duality
the solution is to build on an AI data
Foundation to make AI easily available
to all your data practitioners and to
make your data easily accessible to AI
models
and there are three steps for you to
build an AI data Foundation
first it starts with interconnecting all
your data
structured and unstructured in any
format across all locations
the second step is to bring AI to your
data so you can securely and quickly
build AI models with it
and third to boost your productivity
with AI helping data teams to analyze
data generate code and to optimize your
data workloads
this AI data Foundation is Google's data
and AI cloud
so let us start with the first step with
interconnecting all your data your
workloads are increasing new file
formats more unstructured data across
clouds
and on-premise systems and we hear you
there are just too many tools for you to
learn and to navigate in between
data is spread over tens sometimes
hundreds of data silos and every AI
project is really a data project in
disguise
but there is a better way
you need the Simplicity of bigquery to
interconnect all of your data
bigquery enables you to manage
structured and unstructured data with
fine-grained access controls across all
clouds but without you moving the data
bigquery enables you to analyze and
smoothly work with all of the major open
source file formats
self-managed data lakes and Google's
high performance bigquery storage
bigquery also enables you to connect
large-scale data sets with real-time
data streams
interconnecting all your data
specifically means going Beyond
structured data records the majority of
the data out there is what it's
unstructured and the majority of that
data is never analyzed yet gen AI holds
enormous potential for analyzing both
structured and unstructured data it is a
key step in your data journey to make
sense of this unstructured data be it
images Voice documents you have to
analyze it and combine it with your
structured data records this ultimately
unlocks the real 360 degree insights
into your business
this is why we have just make big lake
object tables generally available
and there they are to easily access
Traverse process and query unstructured
data in bigquery
and we also announced today that General
availability in Big Lake for the hoodie
and Delta file format
big lake has seen hyper growth just
since the beginning of this year Big
Lake usage has seen a 27-fold increase
in usage and today
we are taking big lake one step further
today I am thrilled to announce the
preview of fully managed Iceberg tables
in Big League
so you can use high throughput streaming
I love the spirit of that high
throughput streaming and ingestion on
all of your Google Cloud Storage data
you get a fully managed experience for
your lake house with storage
optimizations built in and you can
perform DML transactions and use
consistent modifications and get
improved security for your Iceberg table
data all while retaining full Iceberg
reader compatibility
but
interconnecting all your data doesn't
stop at a boundary of a cloud does it
many of our customers are wanting to
analyze and to manage data in AWS or in
azure
this is why we are taking bigquery Omni
to the next level and today we are
announcing bigquery Omni for cross-cloud
materialized views and cross-cloud joins
interconnecting all of your data doesn't
stop at any Cloud really does it
so today we are also extending our
support for analytics to on-premise
we are bringing data proc spark to
Google's distributed cloud
now with this you can run dataproc spark
on sensitive data in your data centers
to Support Compliance or data
sovereignty requirements and you can
interconnect it with your bigquery data
in Google Cloud
interconnecting all your data also means
that you need to have a data governance
and data management that goes from the
ingestion of data to the processing to
model training up to model deployment
we have just added intelligent data
profiling to dataplex and those
capabilities help you to understand the
completeness the accuracy and the
validity of your data and today we
announced extended support in data
blacks for data management and
governance covering vertex AI
users will get a single pane of glass
for all of your data and your AI assets
including vertex AI models and data sets
operational databases and all your
analytical data on gcp
this is the first step of Google's data
and AI Cloud interconnecting all your
data
let us go to the second step
let us talk about bringing AI to your
data this means making AI easily
accessible to all your data teams and
making it effortless for you to make
your data accessible to AI models to
drain and deploy them
this makes the development of AI really
secure fast and simpler
our customers already are running
hundreds of millions of machine learning
predictions in bigquery today
in just the last six months ml
operations in bigquery have grown more
than 250 percent compared to last year
and today we are taking the next step by
bringing generative AI to your bigquery
data today we are announcing the ability
to access vertex AIS Foundation model
directly from bigquery
with just a single statement you can
connect a bigquery table with a large
language model in vertex
and you can tune and use prompts with
all of your big query data
this allows you to use gen AI
capabilities such as text analysis on
your data or generate new attributes for
your table data in bigquery with just a
few clicks you can use the vertex stock
AI workbench to build a personalized llm
extractor which then can be directly
accessed from bigquery to extract
specific Knowledge from your data
Faraday is a leading customer prediction
platform and they previously had to
manage multiple data pipelines do
complex joints over multiple data sets
and now not only can they simplify their
sentiment analysis but they can take
also the customer sentiment join it with
additional customer attributes and feed
it right back into a large language
model to get hyper personalized content
and all of that Within bigquery
bringing AI to your data also means
embracing the ecosystem of pre-drained
models and machine learning Frameworks
and today here comes a big one we are
announcing that channel availability of
bigqueries machine learning inference
engine
foreign
customer you can run predictions on
Google Cloud Vision natural language and
translation models you can import models
in formats like tensorflow Lite Onyx or
XJ boost and you can use directly models
hosted in vertex AI
and to bring AI to your data we made
bigquery the place to store all of your
ml features and vector embeddings
this is why we are announcing today the
big query preview feature of feature
tables and Vector embedding indexes
by loading your feature and Vector data
into bigquery you can do powerful
semantic searches you can run
recommendation queries all at the scale
of your bigquery data and you can manage
your features as you manage the same way
as you manage your other data
and plus we will automatically
synchronize your feature data in
bigquery with vertex AI feature store to
enable low latency serving in your web
applications but without having you
moving the data
bringing AI to your data also means
bringing the teams together who are
working on AI and data in a shared
environment
and we are excited to announce the
preview of our brand new and super
awesome bigquery Studio
bigquery studio is now a place where
data engineering analytics and machine
learning can be brought together in one
environment
and customers like herb make it now fast
and easy for the data and AI teams to
work smoothly together across the full
data life cycle
bigquery Studio allows you to write SQL
python Frameworks like spark and other
languages and run it on the petabyte
scale of your data but without any
additional infrastructure management
overhead
and to all of the Python coders out
there I assume there are some I hope
there are some
when we say bringing AI to your data
this also means a simple way for you to
run python for data science directly in
bigquery and today we are announcing the
preview of our big query data frame API
with bigquery data frames you can use
familiar apis for pandas or scikit-learn
and prepare terrain on and score data
inside of bigquery and leverage the
scale of our serverless infrastructure
yeah
and of course
you know bigquery Studio you know when
you write potent code in it you want to
have the best awesome notebook
experience that possibly can be
this is why bigquery Studio gives you
direct access to collab Enterprise
it is a new offering that brings
Google's Cloud security and compliance
to collab
and to provide you flexibility and
choice at the same point in time we are
also deepening our Partnerships with
facts deep node and super tour for
notebooks
bringing AI directly to your data and
bigquery is the second step in Google's
data and AI cloud
so
let us go to the third step
let us go to Bringing AI to your data
Foundation by using generative AI to
analyze code
generate code analyze your data and
optimize your data workloads
Google cloud is built with the leading
AI models
and duet AI is our collaborative
experience that helps you work on gcp
I am thrilled to announce the preview of
duet AI in big query
duet AI can assist you with writing SQL
and python code and allowing you to
focus more on logic and outcomes
it auto suggests code in real time when
it generates full functions and code
blocks for you
and it helps you through your data work
with a chat based experience
we also brought two at AI to our data
migration service to help you modernize
your legacy application through
automatic SQL translations
and now with duet AI in bigquery data
companies at companies like L'Oreal they
can gain chat and code collaboration to
speed up all of their data work
we are also brought two ADI to data
blacks
Toyota and dataplex can be used for
metadata inside to solve what we call
the cold start problem
how do you know
which questions you can ask of your data
leveraging duet AI we help you jump
start your analytics with a generated
list of questions based on your data and
how this data is being used
and now with one click access you can
turn those questions into SQL theories
in the new Big query Studio
we also took it one step further on
helping you to analyze your data
more than 10 million users access looker
every month
and they gain deeper insights from over
1 000 data sources and more than 800
Community connectors
and now it's time to bring generative AI
to business Analytics
I am fired up to announce two at AI for
looker
allows to do two conversational data
analysis in natural language
do that AI looker can automatically
generate dashboards and reports by you
telling local the goals of your analysis
duet Ai and looker can generate Google
slides for you so you can take it to the
next meeting and discuss your findings
with your colleagues
you can use natural language to create
visualizations and calculations
and you can rapidly build data models in
look ml by just telling look at the
intent of your data model
our vision for Looker has always been to
reduce the time between insights and
actions
imagine being able to chat with your
data re-imagine what repot or dashboard
generation could be and reimagine how
decision makers get to the right answers
in the right moment and in the right
format
bringing generative AI to help data
teams is the third step in Google's data
and AI cloud and now I think it's time
we take a look at how bigquery and look
at the AI data Foundation look like in
action please welcome from Google
developer relations Json Davenport
take it away Chase thank you Garrett
so many great launches to help our
analysts engineers and scientists get
more done with Google's data cloud
I'm excited to share how all these
features will come together in a video
walkthrough today which I recorded over
the weekend just in case I had any
technical difficulties
working to build insights on any
platform is the goal of this video today
and we'll be stepping through it to see
this come to life for manufacturing
plant
first I'll open my dashboard
for my plant application powered and
looker
and here we can see that we have an
issue in one of our sites so we're going
to go ahead and click into that
all right
we're pulling up and the first thing
we're going to do is notice that we have
a problem and specifically in throughput
so as we start to look around we can see
that we have a dip at the hour of 2 pm
now with Toyota and looker we're going
to bring AI to our data
so let's learn why throughput is down
why did throughput drop at 2 pm
all right we can see here so knowing
context is really important in this
scenario and what do I just thoughtfully
done is suggest recommendations for me
because it understands the question that
I asked and all the things about my data
in order to make sure that it can give
the right answers back
and in a few turns we can see that we
have some machine issues here are some
press machine failures and then some
inventory overflows so we can go ahead
and start working on that fix
now this is really helpful and with
throughout duet I probably would have
had to take some engineering time in
order to actually get to this answer
since the data wasn't readily available
ultimately though because this is
reactive what we want to do is be
proactive in our dashboard and actually
recommend actions for us to go use
so with that we need to build a model
that predicts our downtime and then put
it on here so we can actually avoid this
going forward
so let's go ahead and get working to
build this using our single simple
unified environment bigquery Studio
here we can build anything that we want
including in Python
so let's go ahead and get to this
first I'll see what data I already have
available
here we can see that I have a data set
that's in Google cloud and then another
data set that's in AWS
there's a throughput table that looks
promising to use as a starting point
what I need to do though is I need to
validate that this data is actually good
because it needs to go into my model and
I need to make sure my model is high
quality
so let's go ahead and open the
throughput table
let's go ahead and open the table thank
you all right
now I can see here I'm on the data
profiling tab that I can perform some
lightweight data analysis right out of
the box
and next I need to make sure that this
data is actually governed well or it has
high quality and we can see that we have
quality checks already in place so I
know that this data is maintained
also because we're using duet AI it's
already analyzing our data and all the
queries that we've done before this so
what we can do is use insights to
actually suggest business questions to
our users
let's open one of these queries in
bigquery to see one of the insights
it's really cool for this because what
we're doing is I just had the question
and I could immediately start to see
things about my data that are really
useful
all right
now we need to actually build our model
and to do that we're going to need a few
more data features and it looks like our
AWS data set has some data features that
are going to be useful for us
since we're going to be building our ml
model though I'm going to do this in a
Jupiter notebook
so let's make sure we can do this to
collaborate more effectively
all right here we're going to as the
notebook opens ask duet AI to help us
build a model
and with this model we'll be generating
a multi-cloud query for us to bring our
data together and then predict our
throughput based on the attributes that
we have of our data
and it can also detect my spelling
errors because I am not a good speller
sometimes
all right with that we have our SQL
query and we can see here that we can
create our model with that also down
toward the bottom we have our join so we
just joined all this data from multiple
clouds in a single simple joint
operation and there's nothing more
complexier than what we have
all right so doing AI is really helping
me not just code faster but it's also
helping me get to my insights even
faster
so let's go ahead and start getting
these business questions answered in a
way that really works well for us
so I need to make sure that my model
will actually run we have this model but
it's based on this table and it's not
based on my data stream
in the same notebook here what we're
going to do is mix programming languages
and start using python
first we'll use a few lines of code here
and what we'll do is actually see our
model predicting in real time against
our production data so we know that this
data is ready for our production
environment and this model specifically
and since these predictions are a great
start what I want to think about now is
how I can actually give my re give my
plant operators recommendations for what
to do because ultimately if they know it
they can go do immediately for
preventative maintenance the plant will
be even better
so we have some unstructured data for
this that reside somewhere else and what
we're going to do is pull that in
we're going to use what's called
retrieval augmented generation which is
a really really big set of words and
just means that we're going to actually
use our data to build tools for an llm
in order to help build an even better
response that's grounded and has more
safety in it to reduce hallucinations
and it seems honestly like sometimes a
lot but we can do it here with just a
few lines to really bring it to life
first let's do this and bring our AI to
bigquery
so using llms powered by vertex AI
we're going to actually connect all
these these data points together in our
models we're going to summarize all of
this and we're going to create numerical
representations of our summaries or
vectors to help with these searches and
groupings
next we're going to pass a question into
the oom which will help us get our
vector and the summary of the closest
thing that was related to that
this will then use to actually get our
prompt we'll pass that in and then we'll
get our recommendation for what our
users should actually go do in order to
make the plant work better and in this
case making sure that our employees are
properly trained on how the garage door
should open and what happens when they
disconnect the power
this would have taken us a lot of time
and data scientists in order to actually
make this happen and here we just did it
in a matter of minutes using generative
AI in bigquery and the benefit of this
is that all of our data remained in
place we brought compute to our data to
keep it secure
all right we get this let's get our
pipeline deployed
and now let's go back to our actual Big
Data application where we can see
predictive results coming through
and with the power of looker we can use
actions to notify our plant Personnel
that they need to take action
all right so let's summarize today we
went from reactive to proactive using
the data cloud and generative Ai and we
made it happen at scale using secure
Technologies and at scale across all of
our data we can't wait to see what you
build with these new capabilities in
your data stack
back to you Garrett
thank you Jason what an awesome
demonstration
now
imagine what is possible in your future
with the ability to unlock the potential
that your data holds
when all of your data is interconnected
when you can make AI easily available to
all your data users when users can chat
with your data
and when data practitioners can harness
the power of generative AI
we believe that your data it's the key
to unlock your AI transformation
to continuously solve for what's coming
next and to innovate in your industry
and this is why we are building with so
much passion Google's data and AI Cloud
for you
and we are thrilled that we are joined
by over 1 000 software Partners who are
powering their applications with
Google's data and AI Cloud to help you
on your data Journey
but now it's time to turn it over to you
get started with local and bigquery
today
sign up into our preview programs and
join our data analytics sessions here at
next 23. to learn more about product
Innovations here are some customer
stories and gain hands-on experience
from our custom our development experts
I am so excited to be on this journey
together with all of you thank you
foreign